and so the idea of a worldwide Sunday
law made a lot of sense back then the
world is quite different today so we
should not assume that after the passage
of more than 150 years or about 150
years that every detail would
necessarily be fulfilled remember Isaiah
11 considering both the Bible and world
history where Ellen White alive today
there's at least a
chance that her depiction of the end
would be different than it was in the
1880s now remember the scholar and the
believer okay this is the scholar
speaking not in any way calling into
question uh the gift that God gave to
Ellen White or the accuracy of what God
would have shown her back when she wrote
but just noting that on the basis of
fulfilled prophecy in the Bible there is
reason to say God is not always
predictable well hey there it's good to
be back with you all in an especially
warm welcome if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise so today
was Inauguration Day in the United
States and Donald Trump was sworn in as
the 47th president of the United States
and for the past three years or so I
have been
bombarded bombarded with seventh
Adventists who are in an
uproar about project
2025 this political mandate has become
quite the cultural buzz in certain
political sectors especially the
left-wing apparatus of the American
political landscape which has propped
this up as Donald Trump's blueprint to
become the first United States dictator
despite his insistence to not be
affiliated with it so it has been
fascinating to see so many seventh day
Adventists prop up the same thing only
for an entirely different reason like
many that came before it project 2025
has become the newest Boogeyman in the
SDA end times narrative that is finally
supposed to Usher in the long awaited
Sunday law which they predict will be
the mark of the beast for those that
might be unaware the Adventist propheus
LG White had a lot to say about this
specific prophecy and it plays a central
role in Adventist theology as a system
in a nutshell she claimed that Sunday is
the papal Sabbath The Mark of the Pope's
Authority this supposed Mark is going to
eventually get legislated beginning in
the United States eventually turning
International it will be legislated at
the behest of a supposed three-fold
Union between apostate protestantism
something we've talked about a lot
before Roman Catholicism and
spiritualism then once it is in place
everyone will have to make a decision to
either side with Satan and the pope by
observing the Sunday law AKA receive the
mark of the beast by worshiping His
Image or side with the true God by not
observing it and standing for
Saturday this will supposedly lead to
the entire world being stirred with
enmity towards sth Adventist culminating
in a death decree going forth
sanctioning the brutal persecution of
sth day Adventists for their refusal to
worship the image of the Beast so you
can imagine that when stuff like this is
being taught as a Surefire thing that's
right around the corner and the
groundwork for such is being laid at
this very moment and Donald Trump is
going to potentially Set It Off there's
going to be a lot of emphasis and
hysteria going on within the pockets of
adventism that are saying these things
which is why it's very important that we
examine them and we listen for the
evidence for such it's also important to
remember that this theory is very
specific not General it leads to very
specific ends so with that in mind
tonight we're going to check in on the
uh chief purveyor of this hysteria I
would call him the chief purveyor Dr
Isaac oloni from Stateline SDA church
and we're going to listen to one of
their Sunday law updates where every
week they uh look at the evidence that
this is right around the corner so we're
going to be listening for the proof that
this is taking place in the shadows
because that's also a part of all of
this as Ellen White also claimed the
people bringing this prediction to
fruition don't even know what they're
doing supposedly they are unknowing
tools of Satan and only seventh
Adventists have the eyes to really see
behind the curtain so keep that in mind
tonight as we are listening for those
unaware Dr O is a pastor and professor
at Oakwood which is an Adventist
University in Alabama every week he
scrapes together various newspaper
headlines and gives a Sunday law update
where they basically try and read end
times prophecy into the current
headlines Dr o is an interesting
character I have to give him credit he
is at least consistent in his adventism
and he's not afraid to shoot it straight
for the most part something many
Adventists are not willing to do
nevertheless for years now for years I
have heard that this is the one this
will finally bring the Sunday law it's
really really happening in Project 2025
proves it so in 2025 we are going to be
paying particularly close attention to
this pocket of adventism and the
paranoia surrounding Donald Trump's
second Administration unlike in times
past though where this same Playbook was
able to be run and get memory hold you
know like with Barack Obama when things
didn't exactly pan out it just got
memory hold and we just move on to the
next thing yeah this platform is not
going to let this one die so this should
be an interesting year we don't usually
talk about political matters here but
that's going to change to some extent as
we unpack more of this throughout the
year and see how things pan out but
before getting into it if you like what
we are doing here and you want to
partner with us and help us reach more
7eventh Adventists you can do so at
answering adventism doccom donate our
mission is to equip as many Christians
as possible to reach as many 7th Day
Adventists as possible with the true
Christ and his gospel this is happening
and the evidence of such is all of the
testimonies that we regularly get from
all over the world and that is only
possible because of our partners and
YouTube members so thank you so much for
your support with that said let's let's
get into
it brothers and sisters
um you know what today's topic is Right
Donald Trump
666 why do I say
that because of what I'm about to show
you today Father in Heaven as the
Sabbath has come to a close as we get
ready to go to the second part we need
to take our time today so bless us to
this in we pray in Jesus name Amen
Brother Richard go to the screen we got
to talk about this when we talk about
the Sunday law update understand this
right here we got to deal with Satan's
fstep plan for the Sunday
law Isaiah chapter 14 outlines Satan's
five-step plan to bring about the
worship of himself through Sunday
worship number one he says I will Ascend
where
somebody number two I will exalt my
throne above the stars of God I will sit
also upon the Mount of the congregation
on the sides of the north I will Ascend
above the highest of the clouds I will
be like the what somebody and when will
Satan be like the most high not in
reality but in
uh his goal at the enforcement of Sunday
observance why because
Sunday is idol worship can we agree with
that and it was set up by who Satan and
always remember God is never against
people but he's against false systems of
worship do you understand this and
that's the reason why I always say it's
what somebody over it's over now I want
to share something with you somebody
sent me a poem on it's over and they did
all the letters of it's over in a poem
we're going to show you it's a poem by
Sister Karen nurse it's called it's over
I it's very clear as we are seeing was
not a wrap okay with no rap it's very
clear as we are seeing T that signs are
rapidly fulfilling s societies are
morally and spiritually declining o one
thing is certain the Sunday law is
coming V violence is on the rise natural
disasters increasing e every religious
group is with the Pope
uniting our Revelations prophecies are
now culminating it's over
y'all so was this a grammatical
historical handling of the text of the
Bible I'm going to keep bringing this up
all the time until they stop trying to
claim as an organization that they
uphold it Ted Wilson told us that the
historical grammatical method of Bible
interpretation is the only approved
hermeneutic in the SDA church yet we
constantly witness folks in positions of
leadership who don't employ it I am
sharing with you from my heart
today because you as church
leaders and God's people need to know
where we stand today number one
a lack of
understanding the
Bible how to interpret it and antagonism
against the very word of God you see the
Seventh Day Adventist Church believes in
the authenticity and authority of God's
word the Holy Bible and it is to be
applied to all people everywhere for all
time the church accepts only I want to
underline that only the historical
biblical or historical grammatical
method of interpreting scripture
allowing the Bible to interpret itself
line upon line verse upon verse precept
upon precept through the power of the
holy spirit so Isaiah 14 is supposed to
support that Satan has a fstep plan to
enact a Sunday law which is how he's
going to bring about the worship of
himself upon the
world Satan's now also allegedly the son
then because they simultaneously tell us
that corporately worshiping on Sunday is
worshiping the Sun in the
sky folks Isaiah 14 has nothing to do
with Satan's desire to establish a
Sunday law but this is a perfect example
of how much Focus Satan receives in
adventism I I never heard more about
Satan than when I was an
Adventist that the underlying assumption
is that Sunday has some special
connection to Satan as the papal Sabbath
a Mark or sign of his
authority so since the king of Babylon
is liken to Lucifer who fell from heaven
for Desiring to assert God's role as
Sovereign that can somehow be connected
to Satan having a plan for legislating
his Sunday Sabbath through the
papacy the amount of mental gymnastics
that this sort of teaching and belief
requires in order to make sense of it is
a testament to how the deeply held
belief is the North Star and anything
will be done to make it seem reasonable
no matter how much reality smacks you in
the
face there is a central belief that they
are will unwilling to give up and admit
that they are wrong about so therefore
it doesn't matter how obviously false it
is they will ignore all that and they
will find a ghost under every Rock
because that's what they're looking
for if this is the proof of the Sunday
law the future of this movement is in
serious
shambles brothers and sisters they they
wrote this to me and sent to me this
week so I didn't want to make you think
I wrote it somebody else wrote it guess
what do you know that since the
assassination of President
Trump he's been moved spiritually since
this there was two assassination
attempts on his life am I right and I
was on I was up on Tuesday I was waiting
and waiting and waiting I just couldn't
wait no more I said I got to go to
school the next day I'm tired and I fell
asleep and when I woke up he was the
president and look at this this is from
the internet it says pray for his
conversion to the Catholic
Church
yes I'm stunned can you believe it a
Roman Catholic prays that someone would
become Roman Catholic Oh the
Scandal yeah Dr o Believe It or Not
Adventists aren't the only people in the
world that want people to convert to
their theological tradition nothing
about that is scandalous how does that
support anything that's being said right
now brothers and sisters you better get
ready I got some videos to show you to
prove to you that it's over did you know
that Pope said did you know that Trump
says he has a special relationship with
the Catholic Church oh yeah I'm going to
let you see it I'm going to let you see
he says he has a special
relationship with the Catholic church
and we're going to show you a video
where he said that he believed that Pope
Francis wanted him to be the
president this thing is real brothers
and sisters you know what's getting
ready to happen one world religion the
look at that the false prophet am I
right somebody am I
right so because an individual Roman
Catholic on X tweeted out that Trump was
moved by his assassination attempt along
with a picture of trump with the Pope
this somehow proves the Sunday law is
right around the corner and Donald Trump
is the birth pangs of
such none of this is proof of these
grandio claims made within SDA Source
materials this is what I was saying
about it being important to understand
that these are very specific claims not
general ones but even this none of that
is proof of even the generals of this he
asked did you know that Donald Trump
said he has a special relationship with
the Catholic
Church yeah Dr o
Donald Trump is a marketing and
networking Guru who says this about
literally anyone he's trying to buy
favor from this proves
nothing yet believe it or not he he
wants to get the votes of Roman
Catholics he says stuff about
evangelicals too and having a special
relationship with the Presbyterian
Church that doesn't prove anything then
he showed a Time Magazine cover that was
photoshopped but he didn't add that part
and used it as proof for all all of
this yeah it was obviously photoshopped
the actual cover is on the
right this is why I am of the personal
persuasion that this guy griffs on the
uncritical thinking in his ranks because
he has no shame in utilizing fabricated
materials to try and support the
overarching narrative so he either
doesn't care or doesn't bother to look
into what he's utilizing which is not
out of character for him as we have seen
him do in the past where he claimed
Catholic answers is the Roman Catholic
Church despite Catholic answers being an
independent apologetics organization
that in no way is an official arm of the
Roman Catholic church or the Vatican it
is run by individual Roman Catholics
what I have found with this particular
pocket of adventism though is that they
don't really seem to care about
misrepresenting people that they
disagree with as long as it furthers the
already ingrained agenda but at the same
time they'll complain that those of us
who are critical of adventism engage in
this same sort of behavior which is
entirely hypocritical but so far all
we've heard is a bunch of assertions
with zero proof that any of this is
connected to their very specific claims
about an alleged coming Sunday
law and let me tell you a reason why I
believe Trump won okay it's a prophetic
reason I believe and I was um at Oakwood
a couple of weeks ago I can say it now I
told my student I had a dream two weeks
ago that Trump won does that make me a
profit
now man they were oh I don't know but I
was like maybe it's just a happen stand
I'm not saying that was that it was
going to happen that that was from God
but brothers and sisters it did happen
look at this to further Society drifts
away from the truth the more it will
hate those who Proclaim it has the truth
been um changed brother Jerry now look
at this 2 * 2 is four but now they're
saying it's five look at it on the
screen right there you see how truth is
being twisted and because of the the
Democratic policies on the left what is
happened is the Bible says the because
iniquity shall abound
the Bible says the love of many shall
what somebody wax cold so what's
happening is is that I knew
that things had to go to the right
because it's been going so far to the
left and that if Kamala would have won
it's just going to be more of the same
and even more right but now that Trump
has one we're going to show you that
there is nothing that can stand in the
way of the Christian
Nationalist and project 2025 from
implementing a national Sunday longw
it's it is over brothers and sisters it
is when I say it's over when I show you
what I I got a
plethora of videos today I got a
plethora of information to prove to you
do you understand this that it's almost
here now can you give us some time now
this is very deep
one thing we do know that in the last
days church and state will be united we
know that am I right the First Amendment
says that Congress shall pass no shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion is a Sunday law in
establishment of religion yes or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof
with a Sunday law prohibit the free
exercise for us to worship on the
Sabbath yes but what happens is we have
people that say that separation of
church and state is not in the
Constitution that's what they're saying
I don't know they and what's happening
is is that the religions are uniting
together and Ellen G white says there
will be a universal Bond of Union One
great Harmony a confederation of Satan's
forces and while everything is in chaos
look who has the
answer the Pope
and this is very
serious this Jesuit priest he's not just
a pope he's a
priest uh yeah obviously Dr o that would
be like saying he's not just a sergeant
he's a police
officer uh yeah that is subsumed in the
title of
Sergeant one can't hold the papal office
without first being a priest who then
became a bishop who then became a
cardinal and finally became a pope yet
Dr o says this as if it helps support
his papal paranoia that he's putting
forward here he's a priest not just a
pope this only further supports my
hypothesis that Dr o does not actually
understand what he even criticizes and
hasn't seriously looked into what he is
critical of he is playing the role of
the King of the
North brothers and sisters it is my
belief and I believe is your belief that
the papacy and apostate
protestantism constitute the king of the
North am I right yeah all right so the
new proof is more wild assertions paired
with cartoon renderings of the Pope and
a quote from Ellen White thus far we've
seen two single proof texts one from
Matthew and the other from Isaiah
neither of which have anything to do
with this Theory but first he mentioned
Christian nationalism in Project 2025
yeah Dr o we're going to keep
attentively listening for this bombshell
proof you keep insisting you have as
youjust flip through a slideshow of
pictures of the Pope and Ellen White
quotes followed by making assertions
I'll be curious to hear what he goes on
to Claim about project 2025 because I
have yet to hear the Seventh Adventist
out there that has represented such
accurately they also sound a lot like
leftist in the culture War who fo and
Screech about project 2025 which Donald
uh Trump has denounced like 10 times
publicly to which the only answer that's
ever given is but he's lying oh right so
when he says the things that you think
help your narrative he's telling the
truth but when it's things that strike a
straight blow to your narrative no no no
he's lying yeah okay exactly like the
leftist in the culture but let's see
what he says about this later but then
he mentioned that people claim
separation of church and state is not
found in the
Constitution to which he claimed it's
found in the First Amendment and this is
a perfect example folks of how history
is often a game of telephone and the
further away we get from The Source the
easier it becomes to distort the facts
for starters separation of church and
State at least that wording is not found
in the Constitution and we will look at
the root of the first amendment in a
moment but the phrase separation of
church and state actually comes from a
letter that Thomas Jefferson wrote to
the Danbury Baptist in Danbury
Connecticut from the Library of Congress
we read in part quote believing with you
that religion is a matter which lies
solely between man and his God that he
owes account to none other for his faith
or his worship that the legitimate
powers of government reach actions only
and not opinions I contemp plate with
Sovereign reverence that act of the
whole American people which declared
that their legislature should make no
law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof thus building a wall of
separation between church and state
adhering to this expression of the
Supreme will of the nation in behalf of
the rights of conscience I shall see
with sincere satisfaction the progress
of those sentiments which tend to
restore to man all his natural rights
convinced he has no natural right in
opposition to his social duties close
quote so this is where the phrase
separation of church and state comes
from not the Constitution even though
Jefferson was appealing to the first
amendment when he said this and the
question has to be asked what was
Jefferson addressing in his multi-part
back and forth correspondence with the
Baptist in Danbury Thomas Jefferson was
running for president in the 1800
presidential election the charge was
being brought against him by voters that
he wasn't fit for the office due to his
irr religious
disposition history notes that John
Adams his electoral opponent ran with
the messaging that Jefferson was a
howling atheist Jefferson ended up still
winning however the accusations that he
faced did not slow down leading up to
the Congressional elections that would
take place in
1802 so after he won in 1800 he still
had to battle these charges of not being
religious the evidence that was pointed
to for that claim was his refusal to
declare days of prayer and thanksgiv
giving and it was with that in the
backdrop that Jefferson had to win over
a key demographic of the American
population evangelicals and it was this
need which sparked his correspondence
with the Danbury Baptist speaking about
this the association of religion data
archives writes quote when the letter
from the Danbury Baptist Association
arrived in December of 1801 Jefferson
saw the chance to shore up support among
a key constituency evangelicals during
the battle over the dis EST lishment of
religion in Virginia during the
1780s Jefferson had found strong allies
among local evangelicals especially
Baptists and Presbyterians including the
Reverend John Leland who had moved back
to Massachusetts in
1791 Evangelical faced unequal treatment
in states with religious establishments
including Massachusetts and Connecticut
where congregationalism was the state
religion since Jefferson had
successfully ended the Anglican
establishment in Virginia the Danbury
Baptist Association hoped that he would
help them do the same in New England in
his return letter Jefferson reassured
his Evangelical supporters by citing the
First Amendment of the US Constitution
that by protecting the free exercise of
religion the Constitution had erected in
his words a wall of separation between
church and state close quote ah so
Jefferson's correspondents addressed
concerns about what the established of a
state religion similar to the Church of
England Jefferson assured them he would
Advocate against any attempt to
establish a state religion citing the
First Amendment as his support the first
amendment is specifically about
prohibiting the establishment of a state
Church Dr o your interpretation seems to
equate this with the potential passage
of a Sunday law even if such a law were
enacted it would not constitute the
establishment of a state Church like the
Church of England now one could argue
that it reflects a particular religion
influencing the state's policies to
govern morality it does not amount to
the creation of a state sponsored
religion though moreover Adventists
don't seem to have an issue with the
government legislating morality based on
the second table of the Ten Commandments
such as laws against murder why is there
no similar uproar from you Dr o
regarding the United States upholding
the sixth commandment legislatively
historically even laws prohibiting
adultery reflecting the seventh
commandment were part of the legal
framework so the lack of objection in
those cases highlights selective outrage
influenced by Ellen White's claims and
they're more more than likely going to
say well there's a distinction between
the first table and the second table and
the first table is primarily god- facing
and yada
yada but separation of church and state
does not mean the government is entirely
free from Christian moral influence
in fact the nation's foundational
principles including Concepts like
innocent until proven guilty are rooted
in the Christian worldview and Christian
morality not in Hinduism not not
Buddhism not Islam they're not the ones
that come up with this that is a
Biblical concept that comes from the
Christian
worldview so the notion of separation of
church and state does not equate to the
absence of all religious influence in
Government Affairs which is often times
how it is Broad brushed it is about
preventing the establishment of a state
sponsored religion as articulated in the
First Amendment not about excluding
moral principles derived from the
Christian
worldview secondly he asked would a
Sunday law prohibit sdas from being able
to worship on Saturday to which in
unison they all said
yes Dr o where's the evidence to support
your
claims because the historical examples
often cited fail to sub substantiate
your
argument Christian nationalists are
advocating for the return of blue laws
which has caused alarm Bells among
amongst Adventists to go
off however there's no record of
Adventists facing persecution under blue
laws these laws never prevented
Adventist from attending church on
Saturday therefore we need to carefully
consider the proof that is
presented especially since you have
repeatedly stated that you possess
substantial evidence for these CL
and just to get out ahead of it let's
hope it's not project 2025 which I have
seen Dr o abuse numerous times if this
is your proof you are in trouble because
first notice the paragraph that
Adventist appealed to on this quote God
ordained the Sabbath as a day of rest
and until very recently the
judeo-christian tradition sought to
honor that mandate by moral and legal
regulation of work on that day moreover
a shared day off makes it possible for
families and communities to enjoy time
off together rather than as Adam ized
individuals and provides a healthier
Cadence of life for everyone
unfortunately that communal day of rest
has eroded under the pressures of
consumerism and secularism especially
for low-income workers so this is the
paragraph in question that Adventists
are claiming supports the Sunday law
theory but then notice what we read in
the next paragraph Congress should
encourage communal Rest by amending the
fair labor standards act to require that
workers be paid time and a half for
hours worked on the Sabbath
that day would default to Sunday except
for employers with a sincere religious
observance of a Sabbath at a different
time example Friday Sundown to Saturday
Sundown the obligation would transfer to
that period instead houses of worship to
The Limited extent they may have flsa
covered employees and employers legally
required to operate Around the Clock
such as hospitals and First Responders
would be exempt as would workers
otherwise exempt from overtime close
quote so this portion of the proposal
advocates for the recognition of a
designated day of rest by Congress
ensuring that individuals required to
work on that day receive additional
compensation and the goal is to try
incentivize them the ability to go to
church if they want and not have to
sacrifice that to go to work while
Sunday is the identified dat as the uh
you know proposed day of rest it also
makes Provisions for employers with
sincerely held religious conviction the
SDA
Church to transfer this to a different
day such as from Friday Sundown to
Saturday
Sundown well the SDA church is already
not making people work on
Saturdays so this wouldn't even apply to
them they just wouldn't have to pay
overtime to any employees nothing about
mandating worship or establishing a
state religion folks many Adventists
have bombarded us with project 2025
propaganda in the last couple of years
insisting this time it's really
happening go read it it's right there
they cite this paragraph yet
conveniently omit the fact that it has
nothing to do with worship nothing to do
with establishing a state religion or
forcing Jews 7th Day Adventists or other
7th Day sabari groups to compromise
their deeply held convictions through
State
coercion it has to do with the payment
of employees has nothing to do with
worship or forced worship or any of
that keep this in mind when such claims
are used to support the SDA Church's
Phantom Sunday law theory which is a
highly specific claim not a general one
now brother loo as we keep it on the
screen what is the King of the South
just in a nutshell symbolic of uh King
of the South in the Bible was usually a
king was located in the south of
Palestine which is um Egypt right there
in Egypt um so toi would have been one
and then after 1798 time of the end now
the King of the South would represent uh
atheistic communism you know all of that
uh as the King of the South yes and we
see the atheism the moral political
atheism um pushing now the Bible said in
Daniel chapter 11:40 and at the time of
the end shall the King of the South push
at him mhm that was in 17 1998 and
things have been going so far to the
left now if Camala Harris would have
gotten it it would have just kept things
to and not just her getting it if the
Democrats and the rep the Democrats have
got the house and the Senate it will
keep pushing it but the Bible says
there's going to be a change and the
King of the North shall come against him
with chariots and with Horsemen and with
many ships and he shall enter into the
countries and shall overflow and what
somebody
now let me just say this to you without
going deep into Daniel 11 I believe and
I could be wrong now but I believe that
the Trump ascendency to presidency this
time with the project
2025 movement is the beginning of this
last part of this verse I didn't say
it's the complete fulfillment it's the
beginning of it because now everything's
in place to put it
up yeah Daniel 11:40 has nothing to do
with Donald Trump atheistic communism in
Project
2025 I would have loved to have heard
him try and go deep into Daniel 11 and
proove his theory by engaging in the
historical grammatical method of
interpretation which his organizational
leadership tells us is the only approved
hermeneutic in the SDA church but this
is the problem with reading the Bible
like a newspaper folks sdas are not the
only ones that do this I'm fully aware
of that trust me but it never leads to
good outc
comes 100% of the time it always leads
to bad outcomes it is one of the
Hallmarks of all of the Christian
doomsday groups and I use the term
Christian there very
Loosely trying not to use the other CW
that will trigger a bunch of sdas but
notice how all of this is predicted upon
or or predicated upon various errant
beliefs such as 1798 being when the end
times or last days
started yeah Hebrews 1 refutes this idea
very clearly where the author plainly
states that he and his immediate
audience were living in the last days
referring to how in the last days God
speaks to us through Jesus Christ the
son whereas in times past he spoke
through the prophets of old then in Acts
2 Peter and his sermon on Pentecost said
that what the prophet Joel prophesied
about was being fulfilled there in their
midst Joel's prophecy as we see in Acts
2117 was for the end times or last days
Joel presents five pieces of evidence
showing that the last days weren't some
mysterious event in our future but real
concrete events within the 40-year
Horizon of Peter and the first century
Church the incredible outpouring of the
Holy Spirit allowed people to hear Peter
speaking perfectly in their own language
even though he was preaching in a
foreign tongue the spirit empowered
people to prophesy young men to dream
dreams old men to see visions and a
remnant of judeans to come under Jesus's
lordship for
salvation the last days is simply the
period from the Ascension to the second
coming that doesn't mean the Bible has
nothing to say about our future it
absolutely does but when we examine this
text and others like Hebrews 1 it's
clear these specific events have already
come to pass like I've shown before the
SDA Bible commentary which is Ellen
White's commentary by the way tries to
sidestep this by claiming that Pentecost
was just a preview of the end times when
an even bigger version of this would
happen they call it the latter rain in
adventism but if you actually read the
text it's clear that Peter's application
of Joel's prophecy that is being
fulfilled right then and there placing
the last days well before
1798 this is yet again one of the cases
where the plainly stated dactic portions
of the Bible become obscure and twisted
and we need the SDA Church to really
tell us what they mean while the unclear
is allegedly Crystal Clear like the
apocalypse but only to the Seventh
Adventist Church which also requires
accepting their novel flavor of
historicist prophetic interpretation
but this single error the whole end
times began in 1798 completely refutes
this whole silly speculation in
newspaper theology that he's presenting
let's not forget folks that Dr o is also
the same individual that said I'm going
to be eating a lot of crow when the
Sunday law gets passed well it's funny
because they love to point to the blue
laws they love to point to 1888 and and
these sorts of times in American history
to try and say that that was kind of a
precursor for what's coming yeah and you
know he just doesn't believe but he's
going to eat a lot he's going to eat a
lot of Crow when it happens oh and so
you know people like that I don't even
debate with them he's going to eat those
words when it comes yet here he is
grifting on well-meaning people holding
his Sunday law updates where he's been
saying it's over it's over for years at
this point go look it up go to their
channel it's linked in the description
box down below and look at the live
streams where the all the Sunday law
updates are and see how many of them in
the title say it's over next thing you
know this guy's going to start a merch
line the it's over merch line t-shirts
and hats and all sorts of stuff it's all
going to say it's over it's over yeah my
the irony at this rate Dr o is eating so
much Crow he's practically sprouting
feathers look at this I want to share
this with you synopsis The King of the
North which is spiritual Babylon the
papacy and apostate protestantism false
religions will through religious
legislation Reign Over the Earth by the
enactment of Sunday observance this
takeover will be so decisive that it
will eliminate the power of the King of
the South spiritual Sodom in Egypt
political and moral atheism and the rest
of it is what take it off the screen
Brother Richard for a second brothers
and sisters this is what I believe is
the
beginning of what we're about to see
brothers and sisters so what we're going
to have to do is we got to show you some
videos and we have to start with the
most
obvious and I know that there were some
I thought of wasn't going to happen I
thought it was going to be maybe maybe 2
3 days before we determine who the
president is but brothers and sisters
understand this as we speak right now
the Republicans have control of the
White House the Senate and they're about
they are six votes away from getting
control of the whole house there is
nothing that can stand in the way except
God except God anything you want to say
on that brother it's a very historic
event that has happened
that is so
shocking and uh America is where it was
in
1888 yes so it's ready to go in any
direction that the Lord will permit that
the Lord will perit and we before we
show you these videos I want to let you
know right now even though everything's
in place to where if they are allowed to
by God we could see something
significant happen as it relates to the
Sunday law I nor State Line SDA church
can tell you exactly when it's going to
come You' got to understand we do not
believe in time setting if I put it out
there it's going to come before Trump
leaves office I'm a Time Setter and you
just I no more credibility could it
happen within four years
yes yeah Dr o I hate to be the be of bad
news but your credibility was blown a
long time ago that ship sailed a long
time ago my friend this is an area where
heeding his prophetesses counsil will
spare him from having to eat any more
Crow on this though because like I said
he's been hosting this circus for years
at this point and it's been over for
that entire time it's been over for
years he keeps telling us but he's not a
date Setter though doesn't want to blow
his
credibility doesn't want to blow his
credibility folks just go watch these
Sunday law updates and yeah yeah but the
gentleman next to him said America is
where it was in the 1800s or 1888 why
was this the case you might be asking
how does that date have relevance to the
Phantom Sunday law and what's the
connection in 1888 US senator Henry W
Blair proposed the legislation to
mandate Sunday as a national day of rest
similarly to what we saw in the project
2025 mandate Adventist at the time in
the 1800s saw this as a direct threat to
religious liberty and a potential
fulfillment of their prophetic
interpretation of Revelation 13 Ellen
White emphasized the significance of
1888 as a critical time when Adventist
should defend religious freedom and warn
against Sunday legislation she linked
such laws to their end times hypothesis
where allegiance to God's Commandments
would be tested the 1888 Blair Bill
heightened their vigilance and
reinforced their expectation of imminent
persecution for Sabbath Keepers today it
is seen as a precursor for what will
come about in the end hence why the
gentleman pointed back to it except
nothing nefarious happened in 1888 and
no 7th AVST were persecuted I know the
bill did not pass but it virtually was
saying the same thing we see in Project
2025 which we read earlier the Blair
Bill did not Target 7th Day sabbatarians
it didn't make worshiping and resting on
Saturday punishable or illegal it had
everything to do with seeking
protections for the Christian day of
worship it didn't mandate that people go
to church on Sunday either but for some
reason in many Adventist Minds this
somehow translates to them being
persecuted notice what the opening of
The Blair bill says quote to secure to
the people the enjoyment of the first
day of the week commonly known as the
Lord's day as a day of rest and to
promote its observance as a day of
religious worship be it enacted by the
Senate and House of Representatives of
the United States of America in Congress
assembled that no person or Corporation
or agent servant or employee of any
person or Corporation shall perform or
authorized to be performed any secular
work labor or business to the
disturbance of other
works of necessity and mercy and
Humanity accepted nor shall any person
engage in any play game or amusement or
Recreation to the disturbance of others
on the first day of the week commonly
known as the Lord's day or during any
part thereof in any territory District
vessel or place subject to the exclusive
jurisdiction of the United States nor
shall it be lawful for any person or
Corporation to receive pay for labor or
service performed or rendered in
violation of this section close quote so
just like the paragraph we saw in the
project 2025 proposal nothing about
mandating worship on Sunday or
persecuting 7th day sabari it had to do
with advocating for and protecting
Christian practice the vast majority of
this nation was a Christian at this time
and this bill simply sought to advocate
for their right to be able to go to
church and not have to miss because they
had to go to work so nothing in this
bill validates the highly specific SDA
Theory nor does it prove that this would
have led to some sort of abuse and
attack of 7eventh Day Adventist had it
passed not a single Seventh Day
Adventist was rounded up when we had
blue laws they weren't hunted down they
weren't prohibited from engaging in
their First Amendment right like they
always have been we're still waiting for
any sort of actual evidence that
connects any of this stuff to the SDA
Church's very specific and elaborate
Theory not wild speculations not
assertions not conspiracy and conjecture
real hard evidence when you're making
claims like they're making you need to
have some serious
evidence just like we hold their feet to
the fire when it comes to the great
controversy theme which is supposed to
be the equivalent of the theological God
Particle you're going to have to have
some serious evidence to back up these
claims and when you're claiming the
whole world especially the Christian
world is going to come hunt you down and
violate the sixth commandment and murder
you yeah you better have some strong
evidence let's get ready Brother Richard
let's go to the
screen let's show
you just have to jump Steve K I just
have to jump in and you've been
predicting this we've been waiting for
it and we do have some breaking news
from the decision desk NBC News can now
project that Donald Trump Trum has won
the state of Wisconsin which means he is
the winner of this race and will return
to the White House as this country's
47th president and for for so many now
um before we show you anything further
understand the odds this man went
through convicted felon he was supposed
to go to jail y am I right yes and do
you know that because he got elected I
saw something in the internet yesterday
where it said that they just post post
they're going to just postpone his
sentencing which means that he's not
going to go to jail hold on one second
hold on hold on I want you to hear this
now if he becomes hold on hold on one
second if he becomes president sister
Bob everything ISP everything is wiped
out he can pardon
himself let let me continue on I want
you to listen to what this newcast
newscaster
said you watching right now that news is
to say the least a lot to digest um uh I
understand that personally after he lost
four years ago he refused to accept the
outcome and incited a violent
Insurrection on our nation's capital
he's campaigned while facing criminal
indictments related to his efforts to
overturn the 2020 results and he's run
as a convicted felon during this
campaign he has also promised to
essentially be an authoritarian leader
to use power like no American president
ever has before and wield that power she
sound like she's not Happ right to go
after his political enemies this is a
man who's also bragged about overturning
roie Wade and stripping away women's
bodily autonomy he's promised to conduct
Mass deportations to crack down on the
rights of millions of Americans Donald
Trump is an anti-democratic Force but
he's just been elected democratically in
our country and here here's what might
be the hardest part to hear but we have
to talk about and we have to say and it
is a hard part to digest for for all of
us but we have to be honest about what
we saw in this election Donald Trump was
elected by expanding his Support over a
number of key groups that we're going to
we've been digging into this night uh T
all night tonight as we anticipated
where this was headed and I know we're
going to dig into it throughout the
course of the day today and there will
be a lot of time spent on how and why he
won and what this will mean for the
country over the next four years and
Beyond but in this moment it's also
important to remember that our democracy
is not built around one person or one
job and I have every confidence that Pro
democracy forces in this country will
continue to stand up and make their
voices heard that's what now she's right
in principle but when I read Daniel
chapter
11 it's going to be so
decisive that it is a possibility if
this is it if my understanding of Bible
prophecy is correct we're not going back
to the left no more we're
not we're
not wow MSNBC is the source now of all
the outlets lying msdnc that's what I
call them
msdnc they are a political operative for
a specific political party in this
country who as an entire network for the
last eight years has been a total
dumpster fire of melting down and making
all sorts of wild false allegations and
speculations about Donald Trump and
because they twisted his Claim about on
day one he'd be a dictator that somehow
bolsters this presentation Dr o is
giving this is proof that this is
operating and about to come
about well Dr o today was day one it's
January 20 2025 and Donald J Trump was
sworn in as the 47th president of the
United States earlier today how did this
prediction pan
out it it's wild how both the leest
cult of our culture as well as the
fingest of The Fringe within sth day
adventism are united with the fake news
media just for different
reasons they both looked the lying fake
news that is undeniably an enemy of the
people of this country objectively so
and have literally been a propaganda
machine for the most of modern history
this is the claim in question you are
promising America tonight you would
never abuse power as retribution against
anybody except for day one except he's
going crazy except for day one meaning I
want to close the border and I want to
drill drill that's not that's not
retribution I'm going to be I'm going to
be you know he keeps we love this guy he
says you're not going to be a dictator
are you I said no no no other than day
one we're closing the border and we're
drilling drilling drilling after that
I'm
yeah it was a tongue-and-cheek remark
that was said in just to essentially say
he will reinstate two things that were
part of his first
Administration how does any of this
prove the country will never go to the
left again and Dr R said if his
understanding of Bible prophecy is
correct that will never happen which
means Dr o we will Circle back around
with you in a couple of years when
you're still trying to run this grift
and we'll see where the country is
it it is almost mindboggling folks the
fantasy that you have to live in to buy
into all of this folks he's already been
president
once none of this
happened but now it's now it is it's
it's just going to be totally different
okay painting Donald Trump as this hard
right hyper conservative figure who's
about to become a manal dictator is just
silly do you not learn from the media
sir they've been trying to do this for
years no one's buying it anymore because
it's silly it doesn't align with reality
it worked initially because there was
still a lot of
unknowns but people can think back to
living under his presidency for the you
know four years that we did none of this
craziness happened it's not going to go
hardly any different than that that's my
prediction because I understand the
political sector and I understand the
political game and how it works but this
guy is who's supposedly going to be this
hyper right Wing farri fascist dictator
that's going to come in and just burn
the Constitution to the ground the same
guy who was the first president in the
nation's history to openly run on being
in favor of homosexual marriage but yeah
according to Dr o the United States is
on the Tipping Point of falling into a
far right dystopia at the behest of
Donald Trump and today was day one of
that now watch this I'm going to show
you an article that I just found today
now watch this we saw after 2016 as well
some of those voices will be Governors
some of them will be elected officials
some will be institutions and
organizations standing up for rights and
standing up for women's bodily autonomy
and standing up for our climate some
will be citizens and many of you sitting
at home right now digesting this news
right now some of them will be
you I wish I had better news for my
daughter later this morning Ian did you
hear that she said she wish had better
news so now understand this is MSNBC so
MSNBC is almost like CNN they're not on
the side they're on the liberal they
pushing this liberal
agenda listen I know Tim Miller and I
were talking about this earlier when she
and so many others wake up to this news
I I wish I could have called her and
told her that the first woman president
had just been elected I wish that I
won't be able to do that but what I can
do what I can tell my daughter and what
I will tell my daughter is that our
roles as American citizens have never
been more important than they are right
now I can tell her that there are still
lots of good forces out there forces for
good in this country and that they are
going to be getting to
work you hear
that why am I saying that we may never
go back to the left look at this right
here Media Matters I got this today uh
when did it come out I'll look and see
when did it come out it came out two
days ago look at this project 2020 25
and now on the internet they're
saying they admit now because Trump one
we can now put this in play
now it says parts of 202 part of 202's
radical policy wish list are on display
in numerous States over how many states
that's a majority have implemented
policies that project 2025 wants to
federalize affecting Reproductive Rights
public Ed ucation labor rights what kind
of Rights
somebody what kind of Rights labor
rights and you know what's going to be
on the agenda when it comes to labor
rights take it off the um yeah thank you
take it back off Richard leave it on
there leave it on there one of the
things that's going to be on the
um list put it back on there my
brother
is Sunday worship
wow so msdnc first and now Media
Matters folks Media Matters is about as
trustworthy as a $3
bill two outlets msdnc and Media Matters
no bias right you're not going to be
able to happen to go there and find all
this negative stuff about Donald Trump
and all the fearmongering of project
2025 no no of course not right cuz
they're a totally balanced they're two
balanced Outlets but more importantly
literally none of this proves the wild
administ theory of the Sunday law this
is why I'm always intrigued when we
listen to administ leaders in this
area that there's just you have to make
these crazy leaps in logic there's just
no connection here at all but it goes to
show the indoctrination of this movement
in this specific area if you get that
virus in your mind eradicating it is a
very hard
process everything becomes support for
this crazy theory that in reality
isn't happening this is just classic
newspaper scouring and trying to read
the Bible in light of your own
imaginings project 2025 isn't being
implemented Dr o i I know you're
probably crushed that the newest
Boogeyman that so many of you propped up
as the one that was finally going to
bring about the persecution of seventh
day adventism
isn't but it's just the
facts but also Dr o why are you lying to
your audience we already looked at the
paragraph in question in the initiative
and saw how it literally makes
Provisions for 7th Day sabari and has
absolutely nothing to do with worship or
forcing anyone to worship so Dr o is
full of it the labor aspect of the
initiative has to do with incentivizing
employers to allow Christian employees
the day off to go to church basically
it's trying to remove what is a barrier
for a lot of people that is keeping them
from being able to exercise their First
Amendment right it's basically just
trying trying to assist and help
Christians not mandate people go worship
not persecute people who don't not PE
persecute people who go to church a
different day we're still waiting to see
even a shred of actual objective
evidence that America is now doomed that
any of this stuff proves that a Sunday
law as the Adventist Church has
described it is right around the corner
that we have a far-right fascist
dictator now who's about to link arms
with the Pope and bring about what this
movement has speculated for 170 plus
years just 1 ounce of evidence that's
all we're asking for you're making these
insane claims you need some serious
evidence not newspaper
headlines I found this
[Music]
video now this lady here I don't know if
she's a 7-Day Adventist I don't know but
I want you to listen to what she said
this is this is um when did this come
out this came out four months ago listen
what she says Ellen G white says there
will be those not of our faith that will
see the storm approaching and will give
the trumpet a certain sound listen to
what this lady says I'm assuming she's
non sday event now because Trump got
in listen to this Faithfully
magazine.com have you heard about
project 2025 have you read the 900 page
so-called mandate for leadership vote it
lays out an ultra conservative vision
for America under Republican president
maybe Donald Trump well I haven't read
the entire thing either but I did do a
quick search of the 900 page document to
see what it says about religion
specifically Christianity what I found
is pretty troubling but first what is
Project 2025 project 2025 is a far-right
conservative program led by the Heritage
Foundation that outlines policy
proposals and personal recommendations
meant to totally reshape the US federal
government if a republican candidate
wins the 2024 presidential election so
this 922 page book called the Mandate
for leadership the conservative promise
as a chapter outlining proposed policy
changes for the Department of Labor and
related agencies this chapter opens with
a mission statement opining on the judeo
Christian tradition stretching back to
Genesis then you keep reading and you
get to a part calling for fair labor
laws to be changed to compel Americans
to observe a Sabbath rest it states God
ordained the Sabbath as a day of rest
and until very recently the
judeo-christian tradition sought to
honor that mandate by moral and legal
regulation of work on that day moreover
a shared day off makes it possible for
families and communities to enjoy time
off together rather than as atomized
individuals and provides a healthier
cence of life for everyone the solution
according to the project 2025 Architects
is for Congress to amend the fair labor
standards act to require employers to
pay time and a half to employees who
work on the Sabbath you may recall that
Shabbat is referenced a few times in the
Bible but most thoroughly in Exodus 20:
8-1 that's where God giving his fourth
Commandment tells the Covenant Jewish
Community to rest and refrain from their
usual work on the seventh day to the
average Lord's Day observing Christian
uh this might sound nice no more
wrestling with an employer about getting
Sunday off to go to church and according
to project 2025 the whole point of a
national Sabbath rest is to booler jobs
that don't require work on the Sabbath
and simultaneously broaden options for
those who do not want to work on the
Sabbath it makes so much sense right but
when is the Sabbath and which workers
would this apply to according the
project 2025 the Sabbath by default the
Sunday so the law would preference
Christians that's problematic first off
the project 2025 proposal is very
Christin centered why would that be a
problem perhaps that little thing in the
First Amendment of the Constitution
called freedom of religion although this
project 2025 Sabbath policy makes
accommodations for Jewish Americans it's
attempting to establish a Christian
practice as the law of the land whether
you happen to be Christian or not
doesn't that violate the US Constitution
Second the official god-given day of
rest originates on a Saturday
historically so what about Christians
who don't observe Sunday as Sabbath as
the biblical Sabbath are they a separate
class of Christians and what about
non-religious folks and Americans of
other Fates could they be targeted for
harassment sure it looks nice on oneand
Project 2025 is promoting a national day
of self-care but this proposal for a
federal law is rooted in one particular
religious Vision why should the
government be involved in controlling
otherwise personal religious
observances you hear that now this is
not a I don't think this a sday event is
saying this but this is very interesting
so what happens is they have in over 30
States and I'm not going to read
everything but what happens is is that
they have a plan and brothers and
sisters you re in Tennessee
Louisiana listen to this right here
Alabama what state are we in yeah look
at this Arkansas Indiana brothers and
sisters
2025 has their hands and a lot of stuff
right now do you understand
this okay Dr o I know that you'll
probably clip this out and play some of
this at one of your Sunday law updates
like you do periodically with me so I
have a question for you serious question
I'm not not tongue and cheek I'm not
playing around genuinely curious do you
actually read and listen to the stuff
you play at these
things the lady in that video was not
correct in her assessment of what she
read read from Project 2025 she made the
same faulty conclusion that sdas are
which is why I think you're thinking
that this somehow proves that what Ellen
White was saying is true that even non
sdas will start to see this stuff come
together yada
yada project 2025 does not establish a
state religion or make Christianity a
state church or a state
religion project 2025 is a group of
Christians that are advocating for their
axiomatic foundations to influence the
culture just like every other people
group Advocates on behalf of
theirs so why is it shocking that some
Christians don't play by this silly rule
that they have to set their morals on
the sideline when it comes to
influencing
culture you know that the Muslim isn't
the secularist isn't they're not going
to set their they moral compass to the
side and they're going to let that allow
and influence the the decisions if
they're a congress person or whatever
they're going to let that influence like
they do we have Muslims in Congress and
they've openly talked about how what
influences their decisions in voting Etc
it's their aaic foundations of Islam
they don't shove that and say well I'm
not a Muslim I'm just a congress person
up here and well we just have to go by
you know whatever the majority of people
think because we can't let any sort of
outside influence that comes from
religion even though that pretty much
speaks to everybody's moral compass if
they're religious we have to shove all
that no they don't do that
that yet Christians are expected to do
that cuz well separation of church and
state
bro yeah the lady in the video asked
what about Christians who don't observe
Sunday because they think Saturday is
the Sabbath Oh you mean the literal
paragraph below where you read which was
on the screen of your own
video then you keep reading and you get
to a part calling for fair labor laws to
be changed to compel Americans to
observe a Sabbath rest yet Dr o pointed
to this as proof of Ellen White saying
even non-adventist would see the writing
on the wall about all this no Dr o this
lady was probably making this video
trying to ride the search traffic of
project 2025 when the media was trying
to use it as a weapon during the
campaign Trail to smear Donald Trump
despite his multiple public statements
denouncing project 2025 I think I
counted five times publicly back when it
was going on and I stopped counting but
this is your proof a random lady with a
thousand subscribers in a cluttered
office Reading from what sounds like the
mainstream media script accusing Trump
of secretly being involved with project
2025 got it okay and this is is proof
that Trump is going to Forever change
America into a far-right religious Beast
of biblical prophecy that's your theory
anyways got it okay but then he pointed
to states that Media Matters was trying
to present as dangerous Christian
fascism being ushered in through project
2025 States they're already implementing
things and what were they oh that's
right stuff regarding abortion I guess
Dr o doesn't think we should heed the
advice of Proverbs 2411 but nevertheless
literally none of what he scrolled down
in this article to quickly graze over
had to do with project 2025 being slowly
implemented in all of these states
already Dr o is reading a Media Matters
hit piece he doesn't understand how the
media a game and machine works but is
using this stuff because he thinks it
helps support his underg guring
foundation of a soon to come National
Sunday law which will mandate everyone
worship and rest on Sundays leading to
the entire world being stirred with
anger towards 7th Day
Adventist yes Dr o conservatives have
had their hands in the pro-life movement
for a long time this doesn't now prove
that project 2025 is endorsed by Donald
Trump and it's about to be implemented
hookline and sinker and even if it work
it makes Provisions in terms of the
overtime pay for Jews 7th Day Adventists
Etc if those employers who hold a
conviction of 7th Day sabot inis make
their employees work on that Sabbath day
nothing to do with worship the problem
is that no matter how much evidence
there is that demonstrates the theory
doesn't line up with the facts the
current thing is always said to be a
stepping stone to the final thing
creating an infinite path of stone
Stones where a person will never get off
the path every stone becomes a dud
leading to the next one which ends up
being a dud and so on yet the person
won't get off the path because of the
deeply seated belief that it must be
true it has to come about eventually
it's like the sunken cost
fallacy where a person has poured $1,500
into a junk piece of of crap car and
because they've already put $1,500 in
things just keep breaking and they keep
pouring more money in because they think
well I'm already $1,500 deep I may as
well just keep going at this point when
no stop you're just wasting more money
you need to just cut your losses same
exact thing that's what's going on here
people like Dr o have been so publicly
vocal about this so committed to it that
to bite the bullet now and accept it was
wrong too much is at stake for that to
happen so they will always latch on to
whatever the newest current cultural
thing is that they can make the
boogeyman out
of project 2025 is just one stone out of
many sunken stones in the
path brother loo anything you want to
say about that um it's quite interesting
that um even back uh in March uh the
current vice president elect uh JD Vin
yes was actually the leader of this
project
2025 and uh this people behind project
2025 are the ones who actually spoke to
Donald Trump to convince him to take JD
Vance so you have a combination of
people they really Place Donald Trump in
office the vice president is for it um
and everything is dve tailing towards
this um um making America a moral
government right and I think uh it's
very important to understand this that
Satan is ready to shoot his bullets
towards the
church God is waiting for
people that he could send as his army to
fight in the final battle of Armageddon
right um you see what happened what's
happening now is what happened in 1888
and the Sunday law did not go through
then because Ellen White tells us
because of insubordination and
Rebellion God permitted it not to go
through because he knew that if it had
gone through with the church having
rejected the message on righteousness by
faith it was a done deal Satan was going
to win a complete Victory so in his
Providence God allowed a little bit of
time so but what is so interesting about
what's happening now is we don't
know there may be 7,000 who have not
bowed a knee right there may be many of
God's armies that are ready to take on
the battle and when I look at this I ask
myself a question will will I be part of
God's final Army right so when the
crisis comes and the Lord permits it to
go it can go and when it goes it will go
all the way there's another video by um
Scott Rima MH on Project 2025 right um
it's a thick book that he was reading
from that was published in
1997 and uh in that book they were
predicting uh all the things that are
going to come you know Sunday laws and
many other things that are taking place
now and it's what what's interesting is
that the group that published that book
is called project
2025 so this was something that has been
planned for a very long time
exactly this particular subject project
2025 has highlighted something very
interesting that I've observed within
the aenis universe for many many years
now and that's the refusal to accept
what is said to the contrary for example
what you're going to hear tonight is a
detailed and dangerous Plan called
project 2025 that the former president
intends on implementing if he were
elected to again I believe very strongly
that the American people want a
president who understands the importance
of bringing us together know we have so
much more in common than what separates
us and I pledge to you to be a president
for all Americans president Trump I'll
give you a minute here to respond number
one I have nothing to do as you know and
as she knows better than anyone I have
nothing to do with project 202 uh that's
out there I haven't read it I don't want
to read it purposely I'm not going to
read it this was a group of people that
got together they came up with some
ideas I guess some good some bad but it
makes no difference I have nothing to do
everybody knows I'm an open book
everybody knows what I'm going to do cut
taxes very substantially and create a
great economy like I did before so Dr o
why not l on to those types of
statements cuz anyone can play this type
of game instead whenever I've asked an
Adventist sitting on you know Dr O's
side of the SDA aisle because they're
not all you know like this they just
assert oh he's lying and that settles
it okay now my point is not to decipher
the heart and motives of Donald Trump
but it's to Simply point out that I
could do the exact same thing Dr o is
doing but from a different angle anyone
can latch on various headlines and then
just string together a convoy of
assertions we went from him starting out
talking
about we went from him starting out
talking about Satan supposedly having a
five-step plan that Dr o has insight
into because of Isaiah
14 followed by photoshopped images of
the papacy and tweets on X to Christian
nationalism in Project 2025 to msdnc
melting down on Election night over
Trump winning to the Blair bill of 1888
allegedly being a precursor for the
current times to a random lady on
YouTube with a thousand subscribers to
Media Matters a known leftist hit job
Outlet where it was asserted that all
sorts of stuff from Project 2025 is
already being rolled out in 30
States and that's supposed to be the
proof that there's a national eventually
turned International Sunday law on the
horizon which will mandate that everyone
rich and poor small and great will have
to worship and rest on Sundays
eventually culminating in the entire
world being stirred with enmity towards
7th Day Adventist for their refusal to
join
in folks do not do newspaper
theology every time we look at this
stream of adventism Walter V Amazing
Discoveries Dr o Etc we see the same
thing it always produces the same
results but then we heard that God
supposedly showed Ellen White why the
1888 Blair Bill didn't go through this
was fascinating wow and it was because
God knew that if it
had Satan would have had total
Victory wow yeah that sounds like an
extremely impotent God lowercase G I am
always fascinated listening to this sort
of banter like a fly on the wall because
it demonstrates how many ways the devil
is just totally rocking the Adventist
God in this Galactic controversy less
than 1% of the global population is the
remnant that God's able to save out of
the world he's trying his best but man
he
just too much Satan secured the vast
vast vast majority of humanity but then
According to some of them within the
less than 1% of the of this Remnant you
know because the SDA Church makes up
less than 1% of the global population
most of them aren't even saved there's a
Remnant within the remnant yeah that
crowd tends to hang out in Dr O's stream
Ellen White claimed that Satan was even
able to twist the heart of the Adventist
Jesus on the cross causing him to doubt
his resurrection and if his sacrifice
would even be accepted by God the Father
which means he lacked perfect Faith
which is not you know lacking a perfect
Trust in God which is sinful the point
being it should not be alarming how weak
and impotent the god figures of the
great controversy worldview are and
Satan is regularly presented as a tragic
hero but lastly project 2025 this guy
said has allegedly been in the works
since the
90s and this is supposed to prove
what project 2025 like we've already
seen makes no provision or or or any
sort of legislation or advocacy of
mandating worship
it makes Provisions for Christians and
even people who have the conviction of
sth day sabari ISM it makes Provisions
for those individuals who are workers at
companies who work is potentially
obstructing their ability to go
worship has absolutely nothing to do
with mandating worship altering worship
setting up a state religion or any of
that and like I said earlier the only
defense I ever hear is well it's a
stepping stone in that direction it's
always a stepping stone guys and then
that that stepping stone sinks and you
just move to the next stepping stone
just apply aam's
razor the simplest explanation is
usually the best one it requires the
least amount of assumptions I I hope
when all of this pans out we're going to
have some fun this year but I hope when
all of this pans
out and the way that they're
fantasizing doesn't actually
happen instead of getting dunked on and
people making fun of them I I hope that
Christians and people that know 7th Day
Adventist will encourage them to take
some time to reflect and rethink some
things get off the
path it's not leading you where you
think it's leading
you I've heard from Adventists for over
a decade that I'm going to really have
egg on my face when all this happen and
adventism is Vindicated no I'm sorry
folks sorry it is SDA theology that has
the egg on its face which is mildly
funny considering the uh Health
message how many of you have heard of
Rolling Stone
magazine now if you were in the world
Rolling Stone magazine deals with music
primarily rock music but listen with
Rolling Stone magazine says Republicans
celebrate by admitting they can't wait
for a pro
2025 did you see that the former
president spent the campaign distancing
himself from the Draconian policy
package he and his allies no longer need
to
hide wow dude so now we're getting a
Nicki McAn Ramirez article which is
pumping up the standard leftist
narrative around project 2025 being this
big boogy man on the horizon yeah she's
not an SDA either Dr o is this somehow
proving Ellen White was correct too but
yeah this is because Nikki is a
left-wing political activist who before
joining Rolling Stone to be a
propagandist for them she worked for
none other than Media Matters the
left-wing propagandist site Dr o was
just citing from this is the same woman
by the way who had this to say about why
it's hard to feel sympathetic about the
United Healthcare CEO that was recently
murdered part of the reason we saw such
a strong unsympathetic reaction to
Thompson's murder was because anger at
the US Healthcare System is one of the
only true bipartisan issues in this
country everyone if they haven't
themselves had a bad experience with
their health insurance company there is
a 99% chance that you know someone who
had a terrible experience but yeah an
article in Rolling Stone from this
left-wing political apparat that proves
that the Sunday law is right around the
corner and a far-right Neo fascist
regime is about to descend upon the
United States Dr o you want to talk
about people eating crow the leftwing
media has had to eat so much Crow
they're growing more feathers than
you maybe that's why you're citing them
birds of a feather flock together you
just have different reasons for citing
them Dr o clearly does not understand
how any of this works he does not
understand journalism and the media
landscape in
2025 he doesn't understand that
journalism has become synonymous with
activism and you have to look Beyond
headline
which is why he should dismiss himself
from engaging in this type of rhetoric
but congratulations Dr L you found an
article from a leftwing activist that
played a key role in propping up the
narrative on the left that Trump was
secretly in on Project 2025 despite this
being
false they used it as political cannon
fodder for the 2024 political theater
they used it to try and win an election
you use it to try and prop up advent's
prophecy but news flash The Playbook
didn't work we see the election
results project 2025 was the left's
go-to narrative for the vast majority of
the 2024 election cycle and it
bombed it didn't work it didn't cause
people to think huh Trump was already
president for four years and I remember
what my life was like but now it's going
to be this fascist dystopia no it didn't
work sighting political left-wing
political activists Who hide under the
disguise of being a journalist proves
nothing other than that Dr o doesn't vet
his sources and critically analyze what
he's citing
from Nikki's article carries zero weight
in proving that the Bible teaches this
Phantom Sunday law theory or that
project 2025 has anything to do with
eschatological
prophecy folks like Dr o need a fast
from the newspaper that's what they need
to do they are addicted to the headlines
which is ironic given that Dr o said
that if you're in the world you'll know
that Rolling Stone is primarily a rock
music Outlet yeah buddy maybe 40 years
ago they they've been a media outlet for
quite some time but nevertheless week in
and week out this guy is constantly
bringing up newspaper headlines like
dude you are in the world buddy you're
in the headlines more than I am scouring
them for the next fix of fuel to keep
the fantasy
going brothers and sisters we talked
about this last year building for a
conser conservative Victory through
policy Personnel training brothers and
sisters let me tell you this right here
on this right here it has the policy
agenda to where they they have the
everything in place for the first how
many days is that how many days are they
talking about it says time is short and
conservatives need a plan I didn't think
Trump was going to win two years ago but
last year but we see something different
the project will create a Playbook of
suggestions that future now didn't say
future president administrations
singular it said administrations
plural so what does that
imply more than one could take in their
first 180 days or AKA 6
months in office to bring quick relief
to American suffering from the left's
devastating policies the king of the
north but watch this I believe apostate
protestantism will use the power of this
political
agenda and there we get the heart of the
matter folks it doesn't matter what the
facts are or how far detached from
reality one must be in their thinking
embedded within this whole belief and at
the center of it all is that Christians
are the bad guys that Satan is using to
ultimately come for the Seventh Day
Adventist yet the Christians don't even
know it they're secretly being used
and that's somehow supposed to alleviate
this slander like Ellen White did she
tries to soften the blow of like well
they don't know they're actually tools
of Satan but they are tools of Satan
they don't know they hate God but they
hate God yeah okay well I recognize that
the fanaticism of people like Dr o is
not necessarily representative of
adventism as a
whole his belief in this area is not his
own it's in accordance with the official
sources and they're really is no
removing the anti-christian slander from
the system
itself left-wing hit pieces random
Youtube videos and speculation are not
proof of the very specific SDA claims
regarding a Sunday law being on the
horizon being ignorant of how politics
Works what the current political
landscape looks like how it functions
Etc doesn't mean the Bible foret told of
Donald Trump or Barack Obama or the
United
States because at the end of the day
it's Ellen White's claims that Dr o
hangs his hat
on and as a public purveyor of her
pathology for such a long time he
desperately needs this to be the case so
we get to witness his internal conflict
manifest itself publicly in these Sunday
law
updates I suspect that project 2025 will
come and go like all the other former
boogy men that lie in the wake of the
180 years of the avenus movement
I'm old enough to remember the Obama
years where this same sort of rhetoric
was being thrown around we have seen the
same Playbook so many
times and it always yields the same
results a a refusal to accept the
obvious and stop praying upon people
because that's what this is you don't
have to believe that but that's my
belief I think people like Dr o I think
they really believe these things but I
also believe that Sim simultaneously he
knows that this type of stuff rils up
his base he knows that these Sunday law
comedy nights are the real draw to his
YouTube channel just go look I'm not
stupid there's an entire target market
out there of people who love being sold
a bill of goods but they think it gives
them special insight into the
future and I know this because I was one
of those types of people many years ago
not as an SDA but afterwards for a
season
My Hope Is that God will free many
seventh day Adventists from these
distractions and bring them to a true
knowledge of the true Christ and cleanse
their minds of this great controversy
fiction which is a
virus no one is coming for Seventh Day
Adventist heck Mo no one even knows who
they are
hardly and the only reason that a
Ministry like this exists to a virtually
microscopic people group out there is
because of my own love and care for
seventh day adven
having a lineage back to the
movement but no one's coming for you
guys I'm sorry I'm sorry you've been
lied to many of us had to come to
realize and accepting this reality
despite these deeply held personal
beliefs that we truly
believed but we had to realize that we
can be sincere in a belief and be
sincerely wrong we will Circle back
around to Dr o and the Sunday law comedy
hour later this year here and see where
we're at smash that like button and may
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace WN by him and his vicarious death
on the cross for Sinners until next time
God
bless holy to
apostate did he say
that come on man